hey what's going on this is yahya
abdulmatine ii i play anthony mccoy in
the upcoming movie candyman hi i'm nia
de costa director of candyman and we're
here with buzzfeed today to take a quiz
to find out if we'd survive a horror
movie i'm pretty sure i will be able to
do that i'm not trying to die
let's find out generally speaking do you
consider yourself an optimist it's yes
no and i'm a healthy balance but i would
say i'm a pretty optimistic person
usually i would go with absolutely yes
but i'm gonna go with i'm a healthy
balance these days are you comfortable
being home alone at night yes no
how late is it i think right now i'm a
little bit too comfortable being home
alone at night so definitely yes you
know if you're up too late it's like 2
or 3 a.m and you're like this is when
dark things happen sometimes if it gets
that late i'm a little uncomfortable
maybe that's really my answer how late
is it because if it's too late then it
feels like it's like the witching hour
you know i don't want to be awake for
that okay next question you're home
alone when suddenly you hear a loud
crash upstairs would you go up to
investigate it yes no uh i'm out of
there now this is tricky because am i
supposed to just leave or to stay there
you know what i'm starting to realize i
won't survive this film because i
probably would go
go investigate make sure nothing dropped
and broke i'm gonna go investigate it if
i'm being honest 100 i'm gonna go see
what the big crash was i will take a
stick or take a bat or a something but
i'm gonna go investigate armed do you
believe ghosts exist absolutely i
believe ghost yes no i'm not sure my
answer without a doubt yes ghosts exist
i'm gonna go ahead and say no not
because um i'm very adamant about this
but because i kiss can't live without
reality it's too much energy it's too
much so absolutely not have you ever
used a ouija board yes no i haven't yet
but i would absolutely of course i've
used a ouija board last time that was in
high school in the building called
masters hall at my school and the board
moved really weird and everyone went
running and screaming and that was the
last time i played around with that
nonsense i actually have i don't
remember much about it but i know that i
have and i would do it again so
say yes okay your phone rings in the
middle of the night it's an unfamiliar
number and you're not expecting a call
do you answer it yes no who the hell is
calling me i don't even answer numbers i
don't know during the day so i
absolutely am not
answering that call also i'm not looking
at my phone at night so absolutely not
that's a full-on no who the hell is
calling me but i'm still not going to
answer it so i don't want to leave no
doubt not answering an unfamiliar phone
number no time of the day let alone late
at night have you ever said candyman
into the mirror yes no i'm not trying to
die i have but i haven't said it five
times so a little bit of a trick
question so this has a little bit of a
yes but the answer is i'm not trying to
die because i haven't said it five times
so your boy got some sense yeah i'm not
trying to die so that's gonna be a no
for me dog okay do you tend to trip a
lot over absolutely nothing when you run
yes no and wow this is specific yes this
is very specific but i already know
where this is going the answer is no if
i get caught in a scary movie that's not
the way that i'm going down um put up a
fight and i'm gonna run as fast as i can
this is specific but this is very
important because as a human i'm very
clumsy when i'm just walking around
trying to do things but when i run i'm
very focused so no i do not trip when i
run you and your closest friends go away
to a cabin in the middle of nowhere
for the weekend in the basement you find
a strange book do you read from it yes
no why did i go into the basement alone
again it's gonna be a no from me i'm
gonna leave that book where it is i
brought my own reading materials i have
my kindle
so i'm good why did i go into the
basement alone that's my answer why did
i go into the basement in the first
place and definitely why did i go into
the basement alone next question do you
lose your car keys a lot especially in
important moments yes no i mean i guess
i absolutely lose my car keys and my
house keys and any of the keys that you
have i will lose them i will always find
them but
yes i will always lose them no never i
don't lose my keys because i put them in
the same place every day i always know
where they are and finally do you
personally believe that you are prepared
to survive a zombie apocalypse yes no
i'm as prepped as i'll ever be i think
that's my answer and that doesn't mean
yes and it doesn't mean no but it means
that i'm not going to be any more
prepared than i am even if i'm not
prepared it's that's you're gonna get
what you're gonna get so i'm as prepared
as i'll ever be i've thought about this
and i'm absolutely prepared for a zombie
apocalypse i know which friends to go
find and help i know which ones would
get me killed
i know where to go absolutely i would
survive a zombie apocalypse
let's see how i did i think i'm gonna
make it out this movie yes i would live
so i got you'd live ah yes i got it i
made it it wasn't easy but i did it i am
the final girl or boy i'm a young man
you're cool calm and collected and we
keep a level head in this type of
horrifying situation you definitely live
and thrive i like that thriving part i
like that a lot but i'm glad to know
this affirms what i already knew about
myself that i would absolutely survive a
horror movie
that sounds like me i'd be very
irritating in a horror situation because
everything would be about logic and i'd
probably be the last to get myself in
some terrible situation so i made it
thank you buzzfeed make sure to check
out candyman in theaters check it out